[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier
comment va-t-il et si elle l'est bien
moins mal et mieux encore alors
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui on est à bois rouge doit
rougir qui est bien à bois-rouge ya
monsieur fred fred il fait quoi
ma fred en fait il là des ruches et dans
les rues scheer quoi eh ben il ya des
abeilles et les abeilles font quoi ils
font du miel et miel les bons potes tout
ouïe cpa diamants mais elle l'est
beaucoup d'autres je vous invite à me
suivre mais je vous en suis plus tout
tout petit ou comment vas tu
[Musique]
les masques les deux a commenté fred
diaz je râlais la forme merci nous
accueillait chez toi plaisir du mois il
paraît que tu as des rues bah écoutes je
pense que tu m'as m'en parlait plus
ouais ben un site parfait
[Musique]
je suppose qu'il ya des précautions à
prendre avant d'aller voir des ruches
d'aia une chose à faire c'est le la
fumée c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'indispensable pour pour aller voir la
bei pour qu'ils restent calmes et pour
qu'on puisse y mettre la main dans dans
un essaim sauvage ou ouvrir une ruche
tout simplement pas bon on va voir ça et
tu as aboya spéciale pour le faire voilà
tu prends n'importe quel bois quel bois
je suppose il faut pas forcément dubois
dubois c'est un peu il faut que ça donne
de la fumée d'accord donc intelligent
finit plus haut à la bombe ou là le cas
d'air c'est à dire le macho cas qu'on
utilise aussi pour la gappe pour les
anciens qu'utilisent les bourgognes
aussi quelquefois et après plus le plus
simple quand on a peu à côté c'est un
petit bout de bresse dedans tu ne prend
pas plus de précautions tu n'as pas de
grands habite blanc de cosmonaute et
cetera ben non quand on a moins 200
ruches on peut se permettre de prendre
son temps pour la visite et quand on
prend son temps
la bei elle aime ça ça la stresse pas on
a des mouvements calme et il n'y a pas
de vibrations il n'y a pas de choc sur
la ruche et s'il ya des mouvements
appropriée à avoir il faut pas avoir de
geste rapide il faut pas sentir l'alcool
il faut pas plein de petites choses
comme ça ils se respectent tous à la bei
avec m
[Musique]
voilà on est prêtes
par la chirurgie choisiront toujours
non tu es sûr que bon là je suis
tranquille à un tube rigole on rigole
non mais attends non mais attends l
inquiète pas dit
[Musique]
un petit peu là on a combien nos ruches
ça s'étend jusqu'aux alors il ya une
soixantaine de ruches au tour ici là il
ya créé il ya une vingtaine juste dans
le cercle alors dit moi très vite et a
simplement comment constituer une ruche
comment est faite la maison d'une
abeille et des étages et une cuisine une
salle de bain c'est vrai qu'on peut voir
ça comme une maison et ben ya besoin
d'un endroit fermé avec une entrée la
plus petite possible donc l'intérieur
c'est creux et construisent des des
gaufres où elles vont stocker soit des
larves soit du miel ou du pollen chaque
rue face à rennes il ya une reine dans
chaque rue ouais en créole rond on
appelle la mer nos moeurs et c'est à
terme beaucoup plus juste parce que la
reine est là aucun pouvoir
donc c'est juste la maman de toutes les
abeilles cas voilà c'est vraiment une
mère est ce que comme les guérillas de
variétés d'abeilles il ya plusieurs
variétés d'abeilles mais la bei
mellifera c'est la baillie avec laquelle
on travaille pour avoir du miel non c
est la seule qu'on peut réellement
domestique est comme ça et il ya des tas
de variétés différentes il y avait une
abeille mellifera endémique des
mascareignes donc l'abeille noire des
mascareignes
qui sait l'image de la population il ya
eu un apport extérieur aussi de
l'abeille du monde entier
l'abeille d'europe d'un peu partout
d'australie liste
pour jon amiel susi et miel boîte cela
maintenant est ce que tu veux mais une
particularité où c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment essentiel de tout pour parce
qu'il ya quand même pas mal d petit à
petit de papa ym-ywha on a pas mal de
fleurs aussi est ce que est ce que voilà
c'est une variété spéciale où il ya une
grosse récolte de baies roses du
reconnaît directe provenant si je puis
dire du miel par rapport à la couleur
par rapport à une consistance au bout je
suppose aussi way au gouver sirigu en
dix mois un petit peu et donc couleurs
mal et le plus facile le miel de choc à
l'heure un peu un peu fluo vert fluo un
peu français et puis vraiment pas bon au
bout car alors on pas se tromper
mon paradis à moins que tu as un grand
marmailles du sens à la pas perdre ça
mieux
au dessus
alors faut pas quand il est mature et a
goûté on voit là tous les gestes c'est
ça il suffit d'un petit geste rapide
comme ça pour qui ne pas fait pas fait
pas fait pas non mais ça fait partie du
jeu rapide
gt il est rigolo nuit
on voit un petit peu de mal donc on voit
déjà des alvéoles ce qu'on voit briller
c'est génial une abeille
elle va sur la fleur et prend du nectar
c'est un liquide chimique dans la fleur
la ramène à la ruche à l'entrée de la
ruche
une de ces abeilles là ces abeilles
lassons jamais senti de la ruche encore
de quoi elles prennent le nectar par
trop falaq si par bouche à bouche et
elle amène ici et là pendant cinq dix
minutes on voit et bouge pas et vous
crachez ravaler le nectar pour le
transformer en y allant là elles font
tous les travaille successivement
fonctionne leur âge en fait les plus
jeunes je suppose whissell qui restent
dans la rue chez les plus visées sont
celles qui sortent c'est ça c'est un
travail à risque de sortir donc c'est
plutôt les plus vieilles qui vont aller
sur les fleurs et puis ramené la
nourriture en fait de l'extérieur ce
miel il contient trop d'eau sylla est
conservée comme ça il va fermenter
il sera plus bon hockey vont sécher la
ruche une fois que la halle vers les
plaines et boucher comme nous en bouche
un bonnet à une fois que ces bouchées
c'est la seule nourriture qui se
conservent éternellement
[Musique]
dans une petite niche comme ça dit si tu
as combien d'individus
d'après toi là il ya vingt-cinq mille
abeilles environ
[Musique]
explique moi s'il te plaît comment et
s'organisent s'organisent les abeilles
avec communiquent entre elles
déjà pour trouver à pour expliquer où
elles sont trouvés une fleur et
reviennent à la ruche et font une danse
pour expliquer tout ça la qualité de la
fleur la quantité la direction par
rapport au soleil la distance tous a
expliqué juste par une danse donc c'est
un système de communication super
efficace elles vont toutes aller
systématiquement à l'endroit où ces
lieux imagine maintenant je veux trouver
un restaurant et je vais faire attention
[Musique]
on peut récolter d'autres produits dans
la ruche on peut récupérer du pollen par
exemple la juste derrière on voit les
petites variantes et des trappes à
pollen et ça c'est un vrai trésor pour
moi c'est encore plus riche que le miel
le miel c'est du sucre et le pollen
c'est de la protéine au niveau gustatif
c'est serviable fonctionne aujourd'hui
pourquoi il disait les galères en fait
tu vas lui fait bas va nous vendre une
folle elle a le look mais notre miel tu
le vends ou où c'est vraiment une
passion et tu es super content comme ça
l'apiculture pour moi c'est avant tout
une passion j'ai une autre activité
principale ici on est à fond bar juin et
toute l'année tous les jours n'a pas
entendu sonner encore le portail mais
les voisins nous apporte des fruits des
légumes des caries tous donc une grande
partie de ma récolte déjà pas aux autres
aux voisins aux à tous ceux qui
partagent avec moi d'autres shows de
l'année
malade et qui paiera
il a fait de miel la bâche aimons nous
voilà bien installé avec bien sûr le
petit café la tisane citronnelle et le
miel de monsieur fred bien sûr il faut
pas bon on est là aussi pour ça dis moi
fred doux nu cette passion mais vraiment
le le commencement de tout début c'est
ça montre vraiment à l'enfance mon
village en bretagne en métropole ça
faisait partie de la vie du village soit
beaucoup de personnes avaient des ruches
mais vraiment en arrivant ici à la
réunion ça va ça a pris une autre
ampleur et s il y avait autre chose à
faire d'accor et tu me parles et à
l'utiliser -que former des gens à voir
des rues je suis formé des gens être
apiculteurs ça fait maintenant cinq ans
que tous les mois je forme un groupe de
personnes nées ici autour de la table on
fait des visites de ruches à chaque fois
ces quatre samedis à suivre dans le but
d'installer une ruche dans la cour une
ruche ou deux pour un complément de
revenus si ça peut être une dizaine une
vingtaine de ruches et puis des projets
professionnels si les personnes qui
veulent ont des projets en permaculture
par exemple je l'aï associe des ruches
ou des projets d'apiculteurs
professionnels pour le coup je ne vis
pas ton activité d'apiculteurs c'est
vraiment une
une passion pour toi c'est une passion
est mais dont la deuxième activité
monsieur fred oui dis moi tout notre
casquette je suis l'auteur des zazous je
suis auteur de bandes dessinées
dessinateur
et puis je réalise des spectacles de
dessin avec mon avoir ou d'autres
musiciens et luna s'allume il ya fred
merci beaucoup à toi j'ai beaucoup
appris aujourd'hui bon je te dis à la
prochaine manière sites ont accueilli à
plus tard elle a plaisir ouais moi je
m'en vais voilà monsieur dame
l'émission se termine mais ne pleurez
pas je reviendrai
promis juré on s'est arrêté dans l'ouest
dans la savane
moi j'adore cet endroit c'est calme
c'est joli je vous dis tout simplement
aurevoir à la prochaine émission et
petit détail très important
on n'est pas tout seul c'est banal à
diament que c'est vrai que quand nous
rentre dans l'auberge mais on peut plus
en sortir
trop de bons produits trop de bons
produits
[Musique]